So it's probably useful to give you a bit of an idea about what assets and sub editors
are available and how you can create and change objects inside of Unreal Engine.
So the subsystems that we're talking about in Unreal Engine today, we're talking about
rendering, lighting and materials.
We're talking about particles that you can create inside of Unreal Engine through the
use of Niagara.
We're talking about Unreal Engine's new audio system for Unreal Engine 5, physics and destruction,
animation, control rig and sequencer.
And again, sequencer being the cinematic tool that Unreal Engine has built in and the control
rig being the animation tool that allows you to create animations directly inside of Unreal.
We're talking about blueprints, which are the visual scripting software built into Unreal
Engine.
And we're talking about UMG, which stands for Unreal Motion Graphics, which you can
create all your UI and interactive content from.
And we'll also be touching upon AI and lots more.